Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, je voulais parler de la manière d'apprendre le français par
l'immersion
et aussi de comment apprendre à parler français, comment faire de l'immersion et
comment apprendre à parler.
Dans une vidéo de Steve Kaufman qui est une personnalité connue sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'il est polyglotte
et du coup, il a une très grande expérience dans l'apprentissage des langues,
il utilise une métaphore, c'est-à-dire qu'il utilise une image comme exemple
pour expliquer l'immersion.
Il dit qu'en gros, l'immersion, c'est comme passer la tondeuse dans son jardin.
Donc passer la tondeuse, c'est pour tondre son jardin et du coup pour couper
l'herbe dans son jardin.
En gros, ce qu'il dit, c'est que si vous essayez de passer votre tondeuse de
couper l'herbe alors qu'il y a beaucoup d'herbes,
ça va rapidement bloquer. Si vous essayez de couper très court, ça va rapidement
bloquer.
Du coup, il faut commencer par couper le haut puis descendre petit à petit.
Et en fait, l'image, c'est la même pour l'immersion, c'est-à-dire que quand on
fait de l'immersion,
il faut commencer petit à petit, il faut commencer par des choses basiques avant
de continuer à aller de plus en plus vers des choses spécifiques.
Si vous commencez le français, il vaut mieux apprendre le présent, la
conjugaison au présent,
avant d'essayer de vouloir conjuguer au subjonctif, au conditionnel, etc.
Et du coup, si dans votre jardin, il y a beaucoup d'herbes, vous allez commencer
par couper le haut et petit à petit, vous allez descendre.
Quand vous commencez à apprendre une langue, au début, il y a énormément
d'informations et du coup, il faut commencer petit à petit.
Et ça, j'ai bien aimé cet exemple et j'ai réfléchi à un autre exemple que j'ai
inventé, qui est le tamis.
Que l'apprentissage des langues, c'est comme un tamis. Alors un tamis, c'est un
objet assez spécifique qu'on utilise pour filtrer par exemple du sable.
C'est-à-dire qu'on met du sable et on le passe au tamis, c'est comme une
passoire.
On passe au tamis pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait que le sable très fin qui
passe. En gros, on filtre le sable.
En cuisine, on utilise aussi des tamis. Par exemple, pour enlever les morceaux
de la farine.
La farine, quand vous utilisez de la farine dans un gâteau, vous le mettez dans
un tamis, vous secouez et comme ça, vous êtes sûr qu'après, votre farine est
très fine.
Alors pourquoi je dis que l'apprentissage des langues, c'est comme un tamis ?
Il faut imaginer que l'apprentissage des langues, c'est un gros tas de sables
avec du sable plus ou moins fin, avec des cailloux, des pierres, jusqu'à avoir
un sable très fin.
Et en fait, au début, vous allez passer du sable dans votre tamis et votre
cerveau, il va retenir seulement quelques informations.
Au début, ce sont vraiment les informations les plus basiques. Donc ça va être
vraiment les gros cailloux, c'est-à-dire que vous allez faire du listening.
Vous allez mettre du sable dans votre tamis, vous allez faire du listening, vous
allez donner de l'information à votre cerveau.
Votre cerveau, il va essayer de filtrer ça. Et à la fin, il va sortir que les
plus gros cailloux, que les plus grosses pierres.
Il va dire « Ah, je mange, je mange », ça veut dire « I eat ».
Et ça, il va commencer à se focaliser sur ces grosses pierres, entre guillemets.
Et en fait, plus vous allez pratiquer, plus votre tamis va devenir de plus en
plus précis.
C'est-à-dire qu'au début, vous n'allez filtrer que les grosses informations les
plus basiques.
Mais plus vous allez avancer, plus vous allez pouvoir filtrer des informations
de plus en plus fines.
Et si vous essayez de comprendre des choses très spécifiques, très complexes dès
le début,
en fait, ça va bloquer. Votre tamis va être complètement bloqué,
parce qu'il y aura trop de grosses pierres, de sable qui n'est pas fin.
Il y a trop de choses à retenir et du coup, votre cerveau ne va pas bien filtrer
les informations.
Donc, l'idée, c'est vraiment de commencer avec un tamis assez large et de petit
à petit descendre vers quelque chose de plus en plus fin.
Et ça, pour deux raisons.
La première, c'est qu'il y a un ordre naturel d'apprentissage.
Ça, c'est une théorie qui, je pense, est assez valable, enfin, que je trouve
intéressante,
qui est que, finalement, notre cerveau, il apprend tout un peu dans le même
ordre, quel que soit les personnes.
Et si on essaye de forcer notre cerveau à apprendre quelque chose de très
spécifique dans une langue,
on ne va pas… si ce n'est pas le bon moment, en fait, on ne va pas vraiment
l'apprendre.
L'exemple le plus concret, c'est essayer d'apprendre des règles de grammaire
très spécifiques.
Si vous ne faites pas suffisamment d'immersion,
si votre cerveau n'a pas l'habitude d'écouter du français et que vous essayez
d'apprendre des choses très spécifiques,
ça ne sera pas suffisant pour avoir un bon niveau dans la langue.
Et du coup, cette idée d'ordre naturel, ça veut dire que quand vous filtrez,
quand vous donnez des informations à votre cerveau et qu'il filtre avec un tamis
les informations,
en fait, il va toujours filtrer en premier les informations les plus basiques
et ensuite des choses plus spécifiques, jusqu'à arriver à des informations très
précises.
Et ça, c'est un ordre naturel. Vous ne pouvez pas aller directement à des choses
très spécifiques.
Cet ordre naturel, on peut par exemple penser que ça s'organise autour de la
fréquence d'utilisation.
Plus vous avancez dans l'apprentissage des langues,
plus vous allez apprendre des choses qui sont de moins en moins fréquentes.
Et le deuxième point, c'est l'apprentissage de pattern.
Apprendre une langue, c'est apprendre des mots de vocabulaire, mais c'est
surtout apprendre des pattern,
apprendre des phrases complètes, des blocs de plus en plus gros.
Quand on parle et qu'on ne réfléchit pas, c'est parce qu'on connaît des pattern
dans la langue.
Et ça aussi, c'est important.
Lorsqu'on fait de l'immersion, notre cerveau enregistre des pattern
et il développe des automatismes dans la langue que l'on apprend.
Et le fonctionnement est exactement pareil quand on commence à parler dans la
langue que l'on apprend.
Plus on parle, plus on développe des automatismes.
Mais comment s'immerger dans une langue si on n'a pas l'environnement pour
l'apprendre
ou si l'on ne vit pas à l'étranger ?
Une solution consiste à parler directement avec un natif en ligne.
Et c'est l'occasion pour moi de vous parler du sponsor de cette vidéo, Italki.
Je ne recommande que les outils et services que je trouve sincèrement utiles.
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas Italki, il s'agit d'une plateforme
d'apprentissage des langues personalisées
qui vous permet de trouver des professeurs natifs dans plus de 150 langues,
y compris des professeurs de français, et de réserver des cours particuliers.
C'est le meilleur moyen de s'immerger dans une grande variété de langues et de
cultures sans vivre à l'étranger.
Vous pouvez trouver des personnes des différents pays francophones
et vous pouvez filtrer les résultats selon les prix.
Et surtout, vous pouvez choisir le type de cours en fonction de vos objectifs.
C'est entièrement personnalisé.
Ce cours est adapté à vos besoins et à vos intérêts,
vous permettant de développer une maîtrise des sujets qui vous passionnent.
C'est efficace parce que vous recevez des feedbacks et des conseils en temps
réel
de la part d'experts linguistiques.
J'ai d'ailleurs pu échanger avec un tuteur Italki.
Pendant cet échange, Nicolas m'a expliqué comment il personnalise chacun de ses
cours
pour aider du mieux possible ses étudiants.
Mais la plupart du temps, c'est au feeling, c'est à dire que je vais voir au fil de
la conversation
ce qui peut intéresser l'élève et ce qui ne va pas l'intéresser.
Si je parle d'un sujet et que je vois que ses yeux s'illuminent,
je me dire que ça, ça l'intéresse, on peut approfondir ce sujet-là.
Au contraire, si je vois qu'il y a un sujet dans lequel l'élève ne parle pas
trop,
je vais avoir tendance à l'éviter.
L'un des principaux avantages d'Italki est que vous payez seulement pour chaque
cours que vous faites.
Il n'y a pas d'abonnement.
Les cours s'adaptent donc entièrement à votre budget et à votre emploi du temps.
Dans tous les cas, le professeur vous donnera des retours et des conseils en
temps réel,
ce qui fait une énorme différence dans l'apprentissage des langues.
Donc si vous voulez commencer à développer des automatismes
et améliorer votre français conversationnel,
cliquez sur le lien dans la description pour commencer dès maintenant votre
apprentissage.
En utilisant mon code promo exclusif "FELIX3",
si vous achetez 10 dollars ou plus en crédit,
vous recevez 5 dollars gratuit pour votre première leçon.
Ce code n'est disponible que pour les 50 premières personnes.
Merci à Italki de soutenir mon travail.
Pour aller plus en détail, je vais commencer par parler de l'immersion.
Quand on fait de l'immersion, on se dit que pour avoir une bonne compréhension,
il faut connaître un certain nombre de mots de vocabulaire.
L'objectif, c'est d'apprendre le maximum de vocabulaire.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que,
parfois, on connaît tous les mots de vocabulaire,
mais on a du mal à comprendre une phrase.
Alors, bien sûr, il y a d'autres paramètres,
comme la prononciation, l'accent, la vitesse.
Est-ce que la personne parle très rapidement avec un accent très fort
ou est-ce qu'elle parle très distinctement et lentement,
ce qui est plus facile à comprendre.
Mais je pense aussi que notre cerveau, quand on fait de l'immersion,
il stocke des pattern.
L'exemple le plus frappant, je trouve, c'est que quand on fait de l'immersion,
quand on apprend une langue,
même si on comprend une phrase,
c'est très difficile de la répéter exactement comme on l'a entendu.
Si j'écoute une phrase en français,
même si je ne fais pas vraiment attention,
je suis capable de la répéter au mot « près » sans trop réfléchir.
Je suis capable de dire « ah oui, c'était ça ».
Et ça, je pense que c'est juste parce que je connais beaucoup de pattern,
je connais beaucoup de formes de phrases
qui fait que quand quelqu'un dit quelque chose,
mon cerveau dit « ah, c'est cette pattern, ah, ça va là, ça, c'est ça ».
Alors que quand on apprend une nouvelle langue,
même si on connaît les mots de vocabulaire,
même si toute la phrase qu'on écoute,
on est capable de la comprendre,
il est très difficile de la répéter tout simplement
parce que notre cerveau, il identifie mot à mot,
mais il ne connaît pas spécialement un pattern en particulier.
Ça me fait ça pour le japonais.
Par exemple, pour le japonais, ça m'arrive encore d'avoir beaucoup de
difficultés à répéter une phrase,
alors même que je la comprends.
Et ça, je pense que c'est cette histoire de tamis.
C'est-à-dire que quand on fait beaucoup de listening,
notre cerveau, il filtre, il regarde des informations,
parfois, c'est des informations qu'il connaît déjà,
et en fait, à force de répétition, il va se dire « ah, mais ça, c'est bon, ça je
connais, ça je connais ».
Et plus on va aller finement, plus il va avoir des phrases de plus en plus
spécifiques.
Vous allez apprendre de plus en plus de pattern spécifiques.
Et du coup, au-delà de penser juste en nombre de mots de vocabulaire,
je pense que quand on parle d'un apprentissage naturel,
notre cerveau, en fait, il apprend des pattern complètes de phrases.
Il apprend et mémorise des phrases complètes.
Un exemple, ça peut être pour la prononciation.
Par exemple, quand on parle au futur proche, on va dire « je vais aller au
cinéma ».
Mais en fait, ça, c'est une pattern.
C'est-à-dire que cette structure, votre cerveau, plus il va la maîtriser,
plus il va être capable de l'identifier comme un bloc.
Quand on me dit « je vais aller au cinéma »,
je ne me dis pas « le pronom Je, le verbe aller et le verbe aller ».
Parce qu'en plus, c'est un peu bizarre.
Mais mon cerveau, il se dit « je vais aller, oh, I will go ».
Ça veut dire la même chose.
Et en fait, il n'enregistre que ce genre de pattern.
Et c'est la même différence.
Par exemple, en anglais, on va dire « I'm going to go ».
Et quand on va parler, on va rétrécir.
On va dire « I'm gonna go ».
En français, c'est la même chose.
« Je vais aller », on va dire « sh'vais aller ».
Et en fait, dans une phrase complète,
si votre cerveau ne connaît pas ce pattern, ce « je vais aller »,
en fait, il va se dire « attends, c'est quoi ce mot ? ».
Ça sonne comme un seul mot.
Et en fait, il va essayer de comprendre quelque chose
qui doit être appris dans son ensemble.
On doit tout apprendre.
C'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de vous focaliser
sur juste des mots, il faut connaître le bout de phrase complète.
Et ça, ce n'est pas juste mémoriser des listes.
C'est à force de faire de l'immersion.
Votre cerveau va dire « OK, ça, c'est bon, je sais ».
Ça, c'est bon, je sais.
Un autre exemple, c'est pareil.
Par exemple, quand on parle dans notre langue natale,
quand je parle en français avec des étudiants,
quand ils commencent leur phrase,
plus la phrase avance, plus je suis capable de finir la phrase avant eux,
de dire « ah, tu veux dire ça ».
Et ça, quand on apprend une langue,
on est incapable de le faire parce qu'on a du mal à anticiper
un peu ce qui peut venir après.
Et ça, c'est juste parce qu'on apprend des patterns
à force de faire de l'immersion, à force d'écouter,
à force de filtrer avec notre cerveau les informations.
Ils commencent à avoir une représentation
des choses les plus fréquentes dans la langue.
Et du coup, un exercice que j'essaye d'appliquer en japonais,
c'est d'essayer de me répéter soit à haute voix,
soit juste dans ma tête ce que j'entends.
Dès que j'entends une phrase, j'essaye de me dire
« toute la phrase, c'était ça ».
Et en fait, au début, on se rend compte que notre cerveau,
comme il connaît que certains mots,
il va identifier certaines parties,
mais il ne va pas avoir toute la structure de la phrase.
Il va manquer des informations.
Ce n'est pas forcément des informations essentielles,
mais c'est important de faire l'effort d'apprendre
ce genre de pattern pour ensuite avoir des automatismes
dans la langue.
Et du coup, plus je fais ça, j'ai l'impression que ça me force
à essayer d'enregistrer un bloc et pas juste des mots.
Parce que quand vous mettez pause et que vous regardez mot à mot,
là, vous enregistrez juste un mot.
Quand c'est un audio plus ou moins rapide,
vous êtes obligé d'apprendre enfin de reconnaître le bloc entier.
Et donc ça, je pense, c'est une pratique intéressante à faire.
C'est que quand vous écoutez un extrait, une phrase,
d'essayer de vous répéter cette phrase dans votre tête.
Vous pouvez essayer avec ce podcast,
par exemple en répétant exactement la phrase que je viens de dire.
Vous pouvez essayer avec ce podcast.
Et je peux continuer à parler,
mais comme c'est ma langue maternelle, cette pattern,
je la connais très bien et du coup je peux la redire à n'importe quel moment.
Je peux en quelque sorte enregistrer tout ce qui passe,
même si je parle vite.
J'espère que c'est clair, je ne sais pas si c'est très clair,
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose de très important.
Et pour parler, c'est exactement la même chose.
Et c'est là où la pratique, c'est forcément important.
Il y a toujours ce problème de "je comprends, mais je ne peux pas parler".
C'est tout simplement parce que vous avez des patterns d'immersion.
Vous comprenez des structures de phrase,
mais si vous ne les pratiquez pas,
vous n'allez pas créer des, je ne sais pas comment dire,
des patterns productives, des patterns orales.
Tout simplement parce qu'au début, quand on commence à parler,
on doit réfléchir à chaque mot.
Bien évidemment, plus vous faites de l'immersion,
plus ça va venir rapidement parce que vous avez déjà des patterns enregistrées,
et du coup l'idée, c'est ensuite de les ressortir.
Là, c'est pareil en fait.
Quand vous allez commencer à parler votre cerveau,
vous allez essayer de regarder un peu toutes les informations qu'il y a,
et vous allez essayer de filtrer sur la bonne information.
Votre cerveau va ressortir son tamis,
il va mettre du sable, il va filtrer et dire "Ah, on peut dire ça comme ça".
Par exemple, au début, vous allez commencer,
vous voulez dire "I eat a salad".
Ça, quand vous commencez, c'est assez facile.
Au début, vous vous dites "I eat a salad".
Et du coup, votre cerveau va dire "C'est bon, on a les informations, je mange
une salad".
Il va filtrer, il va prendre les informations, je mange une salade.
Ça, c'est un cas très facile.
Mais après forcément, on arrive dans des formes où c'est beaucoup plus complexe
parce que quand on parle, on est un peu en improvisation
et du coup, on n'a pas vraiment le temps de réfléchir à tout ça.
Et c'est là où la pratique fait vraiment une différence.
C'est que par exemple, vous pouvez avoir des personnes qui ont un vocabulaire
très précis,
ou qui ont un vocabulaire très précis mais qui ont du mal à parler avec
fluidité.
Tout simplement parce qu'elles n'ont pas de pattern enregistrée pour parler.
Quand on parle, il faut essayer d'apprendre la phrase complète.
Par exemple, je mange une salade.
En fait, je mange, ça ne bouge quasiment jamais, ça ne change quasiment jamais.
C'est ce qui va après qui change.
Je mange une salad, je mange des frites, je mange un steak, etc.
À partir du moment où vous avez enregistré, je mange.
Dis comme ça en plus rapidement, je mange.
Vous pouvez aller plus rapidement sur la suite de la phrase.
En fait, plus vous vous entraînez à parler, plus vous allez créer des blocs
comme ça,
qui vont vous permettre de parler de plus en plus rapidement.
Mais ça, c'est comme pour l'immersion, ça demande de la pratique.
C'est pour ça que les plateformes en ligne comme Italki, c'est très efficace
pour parler avec un natif parce que ce n'est pas parce que vous comprenez tout
que vous allez pouvoir parler directement.
Ça demande de la pratique.
Et du coup, même si vous avez beaucoup de vocabulaire, si vous ne vous entraînez
pas,
votre niveau, il ne va pas être très bon à l'oral.
Parce que si vous devez à chaque fois mettre des informations filtrées avec le
tamis
et vous dire « ça c'est la phrase, ça c'est la phrase »,
en fait, ça va prendre du temps et ça va manquer de fluidité.
Parce qu'en plus, plus on va dans de la discussion,
moins les règles théoriques sont valables.
Parfois, je pose des questions à mes étudiants et je me dis
en fait, la manière dont je pose la question, elle n'est pas correcte
théoriquement.
Normalement, je devrais dire « qu'est-ce que tu manges ?
Qu'est-ce que tu manges ? ».
Bien évidemment, quand on parle, on me dit plutôt « tu manges quoi ? ».
Mais au-delà de ça, même dans un style plus improvisé,
on va inverser des blocs.
Et en fait, c'est quand vous commencez à connaître ces blocs,
vous allez pouvoir les manier plus facilement.
Je fais une petite pause pour aller ouvrir au chat.
Je ne sais pas si vous l'avez entendu miauler.
C'est bon, le chat est sorti.
Mais je disais, oui du coup, en fait,
il faut commencer à enregistrer ce genre de blocs
pour après pouvoir les manier avec beaucoup plus de flexibilité.
C'est pour ça aussi que peut-être vous aimez ce genre de podcast
où je parle sans script, tout simplement parce que des fois, j'hésite,
je commence une phrase, j'arrête en plein milieu,
j'en commence une autre et en fait je reviens sur ma phrase d'avant.
Et ça, c'est la manière dont les gens parlent parce que
quand on parle dans la vie de tous les jours,
on ne réfléchit pas à tout ce qu'on va dire.
On commence à parler et peut-être qu'on va finir notre phrase.
Et donc ça, c'est pour ça que je pense
que cette histoire de pattern et de tamis,
c'est important pour construire les pattern dans un ordre naturel
pour après pouvoir avoir plus de flexibilité,
que ce soit dans l'immersion, que ce soit dans l'expression.
Et ça, dans les deux cas, ça demande de la pratique.
Un dernier point important, c'est qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur de faire des
erreurs.
En fait, je pense que quand on essaie de parler
ou quand on essaie d'écouter et qu'on a peur
de ne pas comprendre quelque chose ou de faire une erreur quand on parle,
on bloque un peu ce processus d'apprentissage de pattern.
Quand vous parlez, il faut essayer.
Et si besoin, quelqu'un vous corrigera.
Mais si vous n'essayez pas, en fait, vous n'allez pas créer de pattern.
Bien évidemment, le mieux, c'est d'avoir quelqu'un
qui vous corrige directement, qui vous dit non, ce n'est pas comme ça.
C'est de cette manière.
Mais en fait, c'est plus important de commencer à parler
plutôt que d'essayer de dire tout parfaitement dès la première fois.
C'est important de parler pour créer des pattern.
Et dans tous les cas, quand vous allez créer des pattern,
si après en écoutant du français, par exemple,
vous vous rendez compte que la pattern que vous avez apprise est fausse,
vous allez la corriger.
Vous avez une sorte de système d'autocorrection.
Mais si vous n'enregistrez aucune pattern,
en fait, ce système d'autocorrection, il va être inefficace.
Il ne va jamais être utilisé.
Et du coup, si vous attendez de parler parfaitement
pour commencer à parler,
vous n'allez pas donner en quelque sorte de la nourriture à votre cerveau.
Vous n'allez pas mettre du sable dans le tamis.
Parler, envoyer du sable dans le tamis, filtrer.
Votre cerveau, il va retenir une pattern.
Après, il retient une pattern.
Si cette pattern est fausse, si elle n'est pas correcte,
après, en faisant de l'immersion,
ou en parlant avec un tuteur par exemple,
vous allez pouvoir corriger ce que vous enregistrez.
Et ça, je pense que c'est très important.
Souvent, il y a des étudiants qui ont peur de faire des erreurs.
Et je leur dis, mais essaye de dire.
Et au pire, je ne comprends rien du tout.
Entre les deux, ce n'est pas correct la manière dont tu le dis,
mais j'arrive à comprendre.
Ce sera une pattern, une bonne pattern enregistrée directement dans notre
cerveau, dans ton cerveau.
Je pense que c'est très important d'avoir cette approche
et de ne pas hésiter à faire des erreurs.
Je ne sais pas si c'était très clair,
mais en tout cas, l'idée, c'est de vraiment faire au maximum d'immersion,
de parler le plus possible et d'essayer dans toute cette pratique
de construire des paternes, parce que c'est ça qui fait qu'après,
on va être de plus en plus à l'aise dans la langue.
Et finalement, apprendre des règles de grammaire très spécifiques,
ça n'est pas utile si ce n'est pas dans l'ordre des choses.
C'est-à-dire que si ce n'est pas le bon moment pour apprendre des points de
grammaire très spécifiques,
ça va être inutile.
La grammaire, ça doit être utile pour enregistrer ce genre de paterne.
Vous voyez une structure de phrase, une partie de phrase,
où vous vous dites, je ne comprends pas comment ça fonctionne.
Je regarde un peu de grammaire, j'apprends et, du coup, après toutes ces
structures,
je les retiens plus facilement parce que j'ai regardé la langue de grammaire.
Mais ça doit se faire dans ce sens, ça doit se faire l'immersion ou speaking.
Et ensuite, je regarde si besoin la théorie.
Si vous faites de la théorie pour de la théorie, ça ne sera pas efficace.
À mon avis.
Voilà. En tout cas, merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout.
Le script sera entièrement disponible sur Patreon gratuitement.
Il suffit de créer un compte.
Et je remercie les personnes qui me soutiennent financièrement sur Patreon.
Encore un gros merci à italki de me soutenir pour cette vidéo.
Et puis moi, je vous dis à la prochaine.